[Musique]
didot je savais pas apparemment l'iphone
5 qui va dans le dos
non mais là c'est le 6 c'est le numéro 6
et c'est mon téléphone qui va pas dans
l'eau
a pas d'eau
ni
1551 50 j'avais pris une coque mx 1,50
d'accord c'est cher à un peu évidemment
il s'agit
[Musique]
on
à
faire les courses aux états unis ici aux
etats unis tout étant bidon voilà tu vas
chez ton petit jus pomme bat en fait
c'est un jeu pomme 2,4 litres voilà
c'est un énorme bide ans c'est pareil
pour l'eau tu achètes en bidon la c 1 4
litre ici c'est un bidon de 9 litres
donc voila tu peux acheter plein de
bidons d'eau voilà là séparés pour les
jus d'orange is it had à limonade et
comme pouvait le voir les gros bidons et
pour finir en beauté ou fini avec le led
donc voilà point différentes marques
n'est que des bidons
comment mettre la honte à sa belle-fille
volume 27 être dans une voiture sans
permis et klaxonner
[Musique]
dit
fais quoi moi j'ai
été nul c'est pas les faire
c'est sérieux j'ai fait la sauce tomate
maison et toi tu dis que c'est pas la
ferme asile trouve quelqu'un qui te
fasse à manger parce que c'était moi ça
leur parle jamais quoi poser une
question voilà tu veux pas manger tue
mouches pas c'est bon je me crachaient
sur moi lewis est sorti tout seul j'ai
peur de toi je vois seulement
et bonjour moi je n'étais pas de
dégueulasse à l'express
[Musique]
jean luc reichmann placé dans le coma
bon ben on soit encore bon ça ça en
corse et encore oui un jour bien
évidemment
important jeu elle a donc terrible
accident président qu'on est d'accord
mais jean luc reichmann effectivement la
dola il affiche toujours un sourire à
toute épreuve théo utt on ut et ben ça
non alors le coma oui mais les fautes
d'orthographe
non